now that you've been introduced into
some of the
other functions that we can take a
derivative of we can now apply them
using the the chain and the product rule
so let's let's do some some fun
derivatives and i think derivative is
all about exposure it's all about
practice so i just encourage you to do
as much practice as possible and it's
really it's actually in some ways a
pretty mechanical thing to do and it's
easier than a lot of the math that
you've learned before just maybe
initially looks a little abstract so
let's say that
f of x
is equal to
let's say
the sine
of three
x
to the fifth plus two x
so what is f prime of x what is the
derivative
of this function
well we use the chain rule again we take
the derivative of the inside so what's
the derivative of the inside well that's
just
5 times 3 is 15
x to the 4th right
plus 2
and then we take the derivative of the
larger function in the last presentation
we learned the derivative of sine is
what it's right it's the cosine so it's
times the cosine
of
this expression right here
3x to the fifth
plus
2
x
pretty painless no let's mix it up even
more let's say that let me switch colors
just to not be monotonous
powder blue very nice
let's say that y and i key i'm going to
switch notation on purpose so that you
get used to the the various notations
you can use let's say that y is equal to
let me think of something good
e
to the x
times cosine
to the fifth
of x
that looks daunting to me
let's see if we can break it down using
the product and the chain rules
so let's see we want to figure out d y d
x we want to figure out the rate at
which y changes
relative to x or the derivative
by the derivative of both sides well
let's use
the product rule we're going to use the
chain and the product rules so first we
take the derivative of this first term
and once again we learned in the last
presentation the most amazing fact one
of the most amazing facts in the
universe that the derivative of e to the
x is what
it is e to the x that blows my mind
e to the x
once again i've taken the derivative and
it's the same expression amazing
and then i multiply it times the second
expression
cosine to the fifth of x
and now to that i add the derivative of
the second expression now this will be a
little bit more interesting so this is
cosine
of x to the fifth right this is just
another way cosine this is just another
way of writing cosine of x to the fifth
power
right and i think that'll make it a
little bit more clear this cosine
superscript 5 this is really just cosine
of the fifth x just means cosine of x to
the fifth so now the derivative is a
little bit clearer we can use the chain
rule and once again we're just working
on this right half we take the
derivative of the inside what's the
derivative of cosine of x
yep you're right well i don't know i
didn't hear you so i don't know i'll
assume you're right the derivative of
cosine of x is minus sine of x and
that's something you should memorize
although you should prove it to yourself
as well
so we take the derivative of the inside
minus sine
derivative cosine of x is minus sine of
x and then we take the derivative of the
outside we're just doing the chain rule
so it's 5
cosine to the 4th
of x
so there we took the derivative of
of this piece and then we have to
multiply it times this
first piece
so
that times e to the x
interesting you could simplify this if
you want but you get the point i mean
simplifying it from this point is is
really just kind of a
algebra and i think you get the idea
actually everything we're doing is
algebra but we just use the if you
realize it looks like something fairly
complicated but we just used the chain
and the product rules let's do some more
i will now switch to magenta
let's say we want to take the derivative
d y d x
of let's see some big expression let me
do something
creative
let's say
the natural log
of x
over
um
over
three x plus ten
oops that's supposed to be occurring
that's supposed to be parentheses
so the natural log of x over 3x plus 10.
so you could use the quotient rule if
you took the time to memorize it which
i've never taught you because it's
really just the product rule so i like
to just rewrite this as the product rule
so this is the same thing this
expression once again we're taking the
derivative so i'm not going to keep
rewriting this but this is the same
thing as taking the derivative of
the natural log of x
times
3 x plus 10
to the negative 1 power right 3x plus 10
in the denominator is the same thing as
1 over 3x plus 10 which is the same
thing as 3x plus 10 to the negative 1
power now we can use the combination of
the product and the chain rules and we
can solve this this sucker so let's
let's let's do it so the derivative
is we take the derivative of this first
term
the natural log of x and we learned in
the last presentation the derivative of
the natural log of x is 1 over x which
is pretty cool and of itself
and we multiply that times the second
term
so times
3 x
plus 10
to the negative one power
and to that we add the derivative of the
second term and we're going to multiply
that times the first term so the
derivative of the second term so first
we take that we have to use the chain
rule we take the derivative of the
inside well the derivative of the inside
is easy derivative of 3x plus 10
that's just 3
3
and then we take the derivative of the
whole thing so it's negative one
that's three times negative one
times
that whole expression to the minus two
three x plus ten
and of course this whole thing times
the natural log of x
we could simplify that let's see this is
1 over x and 3x plus 10 to negative 1.
so we could rewrite this as
1 over
x
3x
plus 10. let's see
plus three times minus one so we could
say that's the same thing as
minus
three
ln of x
over
three x plus 10
squared i think you see how i got from
here to here i just manipulated the
exponents and multiplied some numbers et
cetera et cetera
let's let's just do let's do one more
just hit the point home i you really
have the tools now at your disposal to
do
a lot of derivative problems
probably actually most of the derivative
problems you'll face in the first half
year of calculus
so let's say i'm going to switch to
green so i want to say y
let me actually i'm trying to y let's
say that
i don't know p
is equal to
um
p is equal to
i don't
know
sine of x
over cosine of x
let's figure out what d
p
to d x right the rate at which p changes
to x x's
so once again this is the same thing as
sine
of x
times cosine of x to the negative one
right so we can just do the product and
chain rules so the derivative of the
first term derivative of sine of x is
cosine of x
times the second term
times
cosine of x to the minus 1.
and then to that we add the derivative
of the second term well we have to use
the chain rule here
so we take the derivative of the inside
well derivative of cosine x is minus
sine of x
and then
times the derivative of the outside well
that's minus 1
cosine
of x
to the minus 2
and then we multiply that times the
first term sine of x
so let's simplify that so this is cosine
of x
divided by cosine of x right you see how
this cancels out this is cosine of x
over cosine of x so this is equal to
1 right cosine of x divided by cosine of
x is 1.
and then this minus sign cancels out
with this minus sign and this
and this
side and this we have sine times sine
over cosine squared right so this is
equal to 1. i'm going kind of fast
because i'm about to run out of time but
i think you guess what i'm doing so this
is sine squared
x
over cosine
squared x
which is
actually equal to
right what's sine over cosine 1 plus
tan
squared x and if you know your trig
identities that equals
1 over
cosine squared of x and of course what
we just proved is that the derivative of
the tangent of x is equal to the secant
squared of x i hope i thoroughly
confused you in that last problem i'll
see you in the next presentation